radio pays nous sommes depuis la
médiathèque désormais René marrant ici à
Cayenne avec la sénatrice Marie-Laure
funéraort vous aviez rendu hommage à
redémarrer en organisant un coloc au
Sénat il y a un an justement pour le
centenaire c'est la conclusion c'est la
consécration de ce qui avait été initié
déjà non c'est tout simplement la suite
puisque vous le savez là c'était j'ai
choisi l'année 2021 comme l'année René
marrant comme moi j'ai organisé une
manifestation avec de nombreux
intervenants de internationaux
d'ailleurs au Palais du Luxembourg par
rapport au centenaire de René Baron et
par rapport centenaire donc du prix
Goncourt puisqu'il a quand même le été
le premier noir à avoir le prix Goncourt
et
erroné du sort l'année dernière
c'est aussi un Africain qui a obtenu le
prix Goncourt donc aujourd'hui c'était
tout à fait naturel lorsque le président
de la collectivité m'a invité à la
dénomination de la médiathèque parce que
j'estime que on ne parle pas
suffisamment de c'est vrai qu'on a
souvent nos conversations sur des
chaînes sur l'esclavage mais je pense
que il est important pour nous d'avoir
devoir mémoire et de pouvoir justement
instruire à nos à nos jeunes enfants en
tout cas mettre en valoriser en fait les
les personnes qui ont fait des choses
par rapport à d'autres couleurs par
rapport à nos notre pays et donc c'est
tout naturellement que voilà je me je
suis présente en plus une petite
indiscrétion 1994 date de la
construction de la médiathèque mon père
était le président du conseil général
voilà la boucle est bouclée ça a fait la
suite également de ce que vous aviez
initié par rapport à la dénomination des
écoles par exemple je pense à la ville
de Cayenne ou de certaines rues tout à
fait moi je crois qu'il est important de
dénommer et les rues et les écoles et
puis et puis les les instances comme une
médiathèque par exemple pour que les
jeunes puissent s'intéresser en tout cas
au parcours de la personne qu'on a
choisi pour dénommé telle structure ou
pas et et moi je trouve ça assez bien ça
reste toujours dans la même continuité
que lorsque j'étais aux affaires et que
voilà on mettait on valorisait en tout
cas les personnes qui avaient été en
pleine action dans notre pays enfin des
personnes qu'on doit pas oublier